avec nous maintenant pour revenir sur le
g7 brigitte alepin qui est fiscaliste
professeur de comptabilité à
l'université du québec en outaouais
bonsoir brigitte alepin bonsoir qu'est
ce qui fait que cette fois ci le g7 est
arrivé à une entente avec un impôt
minimum de 15 pour ça probablement que
cette pandémie nous amène sauf de
changement évidemment avec la pandémie
les pays se sont endettés on cherche des
sources de revenus concurremment ça les
grandes multinationales milliardaire les
géants du web se sont enrichis on sait
que ces multinationales là ne perd
toujours pas leur juste part d'impôts et
peut-être l'administration byden qui
amène ce changement c'est elle et elle
en baisse - et donc un momento mme
perfect storm de plusieurs critères
ensemble qui amène cet espoir de
changement et quels sont donc les
entreprises qui sont ou seraient visés
par l'impôt minimum mondial
on parle de sociétés qui ont un chiffre
d'affaires de 750 millions d'euros dont
environ 900 millions $ au niveau
international donc concrètement c'est
environ 2000 multinationales dans le
monde et on parle aussi principalement
des géants du web dont six
multinationales qui réussissent à
profiter de l'économie numérique et qui
présentement on sait qu'ils paient pas
leur juste part d'impôts mais pas que
les géants du web on s'est toutes les
entreprises 750 millions d'euros et +
wii toutes les entreprises sont visés
mais concrètement si ce qui cible et
c'est vraiment principalement les
éventuels l'entente est au g7 maintenant
il faut aller au g20 le mois prochain
éventuellement l'adhésion d'une majorité
pays de l'oscd donc c'est pas
complètement acquis non rien n'est
acquis mais c'est sûr que c'est vraiment
incroyable que les pays du g7 se sont
entendus pour
impôt minimum mondial il n'y a pas si
longtemps on parlait de conversations
utopique lorsqu'on parlait d' impôt
minimum mondial donc l'avant c'est
vraiment incroyable
mais la prochaine étape on est en vo
devant le g20 ou suivent un lien qui est
acquis certains pays qui pourrait ne pas
accepter et par la suite on pas non
seulement 8 pays d'ocd amont par des
pays du cadre est plus vif de l' ocde
qui recueille qui réunit 140 pays
donc il ya plusieurs états c'est ce que
c'est pas en 2021 qu'on va voir les
plantations de cette norme de cet impôt
mondial ni en 2022 probablement
peut-être en 2023 pourrait fort et donc
c'est ça va prendre un certain temps
encore
même si les paradis fiscaux n'adhère pas
à la politique
est ce que les entreprises devraient
quand même payer plus d'impôts oui c'est
ça qui est génial avec l'impôt minimum
mondial c'est que dans le passé
lorsqu'on parlait de réforme fiscale
mondiale ou comment moderniser nos
régimes et position on pense à des raids
qui on se disait robin c'est ce que les
180 pays vont pas adhéré à ça donc ça
c'est rare et de de pensée de mettre des
règles efficaces en place mais avec
l'impôt minimum audience qui est génial
c'est que même si certains pays où
certains paradis fiscaux ni à des
reports les multinationales qui font
affaire dans ces paradis fiscaux la vo
est assujetti elle s'est faite au
minimum donc concrètement ce bon puisque
le canada supporte la mesure ces
multinationales canadiennes fait affaire
dans des paradis fiscaux des contre
exemples des banques par exemple font à
sa dose de québec par exemple ou est ce
que le taux d'imposition est de zéro au
niveau corporatif
c'est les revenus qui seraient réalisés
dans ces paradis fiscaux seraient
assujettis à cet impôt minimum mondial
de 15% très intéressant ça cet aspect là
de
0 à 15 donc n'y aurait plus beaucoup
davantage finalement être dans un
paradis fiscal mais en même temps est-ce
que 15 % s'il suffisant brigitte alepin
mais on aurait pu on aurait pu espérer
autour de 21% d'ailleurs
d'administration bad entend longtemps
cependant plusieurs semaines suggéré 21%
on est descendu à pied pour simple au
niveau politique c'est peut-être plus
réaliste de croire que les pays vont
adhérer la mesure si on met le taux à 15
%
bien sûr comme c'est discale souvent on
est planté une mesure par pressé et metz
le taux est bas par la suite un fou que
le principe est accepté on augmente les
taux d'imposition dont il va par état
c'est peut-être une bonne approche dans
la situation actuelle
parfait c'est ce qu'on va voir merci
beaucoup pour ses explications à
brigitte alepin ce soir merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit